on en a parlé tout à l'heure avec notre
invité régis ou paie les analystes
géopolitiques et directeur exécutif
d'interpol conseil
le tchad a toujours été cette poste
impôts qui permet justement à ce que le
ciel ne tombe pas si vous voulez dans
une espèce de dia distant tropicales
dont ce qui fait que le président idriss
déby j'ai pas le décès du père a
toujours été soutenue parce
qu'effectivement c'est un homme de
guerre chf ses chefs militaires de
première de deux premières envergure et
donc la france a toujours soutenu le
privant des vies en dépit justement du
caractère autocrate et voit des
tutoriels donc de son pouvoir
c'est un président et un gouvernement
c'est un régime qui a toujours été
soutenue parce que il était bien sûr en
pointe et ça il faut le dire la
méridienne a toujours été la plus
aguerrie la plus forte la plus
professionnelle
face au mondialisme et face au terrible
ce qui fait que justement en dépit de la
nature du régime
idriss déby je vous suis compter sur les
pouvoirs français successifs mitterrand
jusqu'à emmanuel macron et si vous
voulez c'est un soutien qui est
stratégique est qui et qui fait que
justement idriss déby fils a fait
l'actuel président aussi bénéficier
encore donc du soutien jeudi ont été
mesurées de la part du gouvernement
français